The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: We'll be talking
about the diode and charge
separation inside
of a solar cell.
So at the end of
last class, we ended
with this little
demonstration right here,
where after much
discussion about band
gaps and light
absorption, we agreed
that that little
piece of silicon
there should be
absorbing the light
and free charges should be
generated inside the silicon.
But without some
fixed fields, some
built in field inside
of the silicon material,
it wasn't possible to
measure any current output
once we shown light on it.
And that made sense.
There were free charges
being generated,
but due to Brownian motion,
there was no net charge flow.
They were just moving
around with no net movement.
And as a result,
there was no current.
Now if we attach the
batteries in series,
the batteries apply to field
across this little piece
of silicon resulting
in current flow-- more
precisely, drift current
across that piece of silicon.
And today we're
going to be talking
about how the solar cell device
has a built in electric field.
So obviously we don't want
an external power source.
We don't want to have a
set of batteries attached.
That defeats the purpose of an
autonomous energy generation
device.
We'll be talking about
how the built in field
inside of a solar
cell comes into being.
As we've followed in
the last few classes,
we will be discussing
physics when it is necessary,
taking a very
engineering approach
to this so as to keep everybody
from a business background,
from a mechanical
engineering background,
and from a material science
background on the same page.
We will have, in the
lecture, I think n plus 2.
Very physics-y
lecture, and we'll
be getting to the nitty-gritty
of semiconductor physics
and how it relates to
solar cell devices.
So for those of you
who are already experts
in this material, bear with me.
And again, try to relate
to the solar cell device.
You may not have had that
connection in previous lectures
in previous classes.
So we'll jump right on in.
To remind everybody, you're
here in the fundamentals.
We'll be getting
to the technologies
and cross cutting
themes after we really
have a good, solid understanding
of how a solar cell works.
The conversion efficiency is the
output energy versus the input.
We have our inputs in the solar
spectrum, the outputs in charge
collection, and we've been
steadily making progress
down toward the outputs here.
We discussed the
solar spectrum, then
light absorption, the
charge excitation,
and finally now we're on to
charge drift and diffusion.
So we have the total
solar cell efficiency
as a product of all the
individual processes.
And any one of these
processes can kill
the efficiency of the device.
That's why it's important
to think about your device
like so.
And just not to make this
introduction so boring,
I want to really
emphasize this point.
So I'm making it
over and over again.
But I wanted to relate this
to other engineering devices
as well.
Namely, today it's
a Toyota Prius.
These are all the
components inside of a Prius
that have to work well
for the car to function.
If one of these
components, let's say
this one, the inverter, is
broken or not functioning well,
you're not going to have the
car in an autonomous mode.
So in a similar
manner, in a solar cell
we have to have all the
different pieces working
well together.
So the essence of
charge separation,
we're going to begin our
exploration of charge
separation using
the diode analogy.
And just to situate
everybody, I brought
in a number of small discrete
components, small diodes.
Those are the ones
that are orange-ish
that have two leads coming out.
There are a bunch of
transistors in here as well.
Those have three little
leads coming out.
You'll be able to
distinguish them.
But just to situate
ourselves, these are diodes.
The essence of a diode is that
you have a dissimilar material
on either side of the device.
That's why I've worn these
dissimilar colors today
to denote that on
different sides.
And of course, you have this
mixed region in the middle.
We have here an n and
a p on either side.
And if current is attempting
to flow in one direction,
it will be barred.
But if it attempts to flow
in the other direction,
it will go through
rather easily.
That's the essence
of what a diode is.
How is it made?
Well, we're
manufacturing materials
of the same base element.
Let's say, silicon.
But we're doing
something special
to the material to add
particular types of charges
on either side.
We call doping.
And we'll get to
that in a few slides.
Why do we care about diodes?
Well, this is the essence
of charge separation.
And this is what drives the
voltage inside of a solar cell
device.
That's why we care.
It's pretty important for
at least understanding
the traditional
semiconductor-based solar cells
like this one here.
So for those history
folks, I figured
I would add a quick
at description.
You typically see
the diode represented
like this in an
equivalent circuit
diagram, a little triangle
and a line orthogonal
to the direction of
the current path.
And does anybody know
where that comes from?
No?
All right.
So back in the day
of that, we used
to have vacuum tube components
for a lot of our-- I
would say the discrete
components within our circuits.
In the case of a diode, you
could envision a very simple
one where you have a filament
that by thermionic emission
heats electrons off
of the filament,
and then they're collected by
this other collector up top.
If you remember our etymology
in Greek, ana is above,
cata is below.
Catatombs, right?
Catatonic, below.
So the anode up above is
collecting these electrons,
and then the electron
flow is moving
like this, which means that
our current flow, defined
as the flow of
positive charge, is
moving the opposite direction.
And that's why we have a similar
representation right here
from our vacuum technology.
You could envision
also a point where
the field is
concentrated at that tip
and electrons are spreading off.
So learning objectives.
Today is going to be rather
intense, rather dense.
And so we will be trying to hold
as much as possible in our RAM,
so that by the end of class
we can really truly understand
the solar cell as an entirety.
If you get lost along
the way, come back
to these learning objectives.
They're like flag
posts along the way.
So you can find yourself again.
What we're going to
do first is describe
how the conductivity
of a semiconductor
can be modified by the
intentional introduction
of dopants.
What this means is
we're going to learn
how to create the n
and the p over here.
So if we look at a
semiconductor such as silicon--
this is a little piece
of silicon right here.
Here's a silicon-based
solar cell.
It's a fairly easy
semiconductor to understand.
It's what's called a
unary semiconductor.
It means it's comprised
of one element.
Silicon right here in
the periodic table.
This is just an excerpt
from the rightmost side
of the periodic table.
And silicon has 4
valence electrons.
So it forms what are called
sp3 hybridized orbitals when
it's in a crystal structure.
It has four bonds with
its nearest neighbors,
all of equivalent type.
And those are covalent bonds.
So you can envision that if
you were to introduce an atom
and substitute out one
silicon atom in that lattice
for something else that
has 5 valence electrons,
such as a phosphorus, it's
almost of equivalent size.
So those material
scientists in the room
from the Hume-Rothery
rules, you should
be able to estimate that the
miscibility is rather large.
In other words, that you could
mix in a high concentration
of phosphorus into your
silicon given the similar size
and similar atomic structure.
Electronic structure, rather.
So you substitute here
a group 5 element.
Silicon is a group 4 element, as
is carbon, germanium, and tin.
So we substitute in
a group 5 element.
Let's say a phosphorus atom in
for one of our silicon atoms
right here.
And this phosphorus
atom will have
4 plus 1 valence electrons.
So those 4 valence
electrons will
bond to the silicon atoms,
the nearest neighbors.
And that one extra valence
electron will be left over.
It will have nobody to bond to.
And we'll describe
mathematically
what happens to that
electron in a minute.
But in principle,
just intuitively you
should be able to understand
that that electron should
be able to be
removed rather easily
and move around the
lattice with relative ease.
Likewise, instead of moving one
to the right, if we move one
to the left into our
group 3 column here,
we can dope our material
with a boron atom, let's say.
Substituting one silicon
atom for a boron atom.
Boron has 3 valence electrons.
Now, those 3 will form bonds
with the 3 silicon atoms.
And then you'll
have a missing bond,
a missing electron if you will.
That will be a hole.
So with phosphorus, or
group 5 elements in silicon,
we can dope the
material with electrons.
And with group 3
elements in silicon,
we can dope the
material with holes.
And this is interesting
because now we
can arbitrarily change the
density of charge carriers
in our bands.
As long as these
holes and electrons
can become dissociated
from the dopant atoms
and move freely
around the lattice.
So that's a big
question, how easy
is it to remove that electron
around the phosphorus atom?
If you want to think
about this electron just
from a quantum
mechanical sense, you
could almost envision that
this electron is attracted
to the phosphorus atom
because the phosphorus has
one extra proton than
the silicon, right?
So it has a positive
charge here in the nucleus.
And here's a negative charge.
In net, they balance out.
But if the electron
goes too far away,
it will feel that
attractive potential back
and be drawn back towards
the phosphorus atom.
So the big question is,
what is the binding energy
of that electron to
the phosphorus atom?
And a simple way
to think about it
is through a hydrogenic model.
If you consider a hydrogen atom
to have an electron surrounding
it, then that binding
energy is well-defined.
But in the case of a phosphorus
atom within a silicon lattice,
it's a little trickier.
Because now we have to
worry about the electron
screening coming from the
other elements in our lattice.
And we also have to worry about
a property of the electron
in a crystal, which changes
the mobility of that electron
through the crystal.
So what we do is we
treat this as a hydrogen
atom, 13.6 eV binding energy.
But then we do a
couple of things.
We account for
electron screening
and we account for what
we call effective mass.
We'll get back to
this in a few lectures
and describe exactly
what this is here.
We need a little bit more
semiconductor physics
to understand it
in its entirety.
But think about an electron
moving in a crystal
as moving differently
than moving
in free space in a vacuum.
That's what this
term here is about.
This other term, the epsilon,
is rather straightforward.
It's the electron screening.
It's the fact that you have
so many other electrons
in your system here that
screening the charges,
screening the electron from
the extra positive charge
in the nucleus here.
And so it becomes easier for
that electron to move away.
This is about a factor of
0.1, the effective mass.
And that's about 1/100.
And so overall, we're
reducing the binding energy
by about a factor of 1,000 down
to about 10 m eV in practice.
So if we were to run through
the calculation for silicon,
the binding energy of that
electron around the phosphorus
atom in the silicon lattice
would be around 10 m
eV on that order.
And that is very,
very small compared
to the thermal energy in your
system, just kt, Boltzmann's
constant times the
temperature in Kelvin,
we have a thermal
energy somewhere
on the order of 26 m eV.
And that's enough to
dissociate that electron
and allow it to move freely
throughout the lattice.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Is that
electron screening
related to the [INAUDIBLE]
constant at all?
PROFESSOR: Yes, absolutely.
AUDIENCE: I just had
a [INAUDIBLE] question
about the holes.
So I understand that-- I can
imagine an electron moving
around in the lattice.
But I imagine that
a hole moving would
be forming a bond-- breaking
and forming bonds over and over.
Does that actually happen,
or are the electrons
more free to move?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
This is an excellent question.
The question, if
I may paraphrase,
relates to the hole and
electron mobilities.
How easy is it for them to
move around the lattice?
And typically, the hole
mobility is about a third
of the electron
mobility in silicon.
So absolutely, it is a
little bit more difficult
for those holes to move around.
Holes, you may recall,
are quasi-particles.
OK, so we have an
understanding of doping,
a rough understanding
at this point.
We understand that if we dope a
certain type of material, let's
say our n-type material,
with phosphorus,
we have an excess of electrons.
And if we dope another
type of material
with an excess of, say,
boron, we would then
introduce a large
number of holes
and the material might have
a majority conductivity
through our holes.
Hence, we call it p-type.
n and p comes from
negative and positive.
Negative being the
electron charge
and positive being
the hole charge.
So that's where the n-
and p-type come from.
Great.
So now, pictorially
we're going to draw
a pn-junction or a junction with
our fixed and mobile charges.
OK, so let's start out with a
simple review of Gauss' law.
Spatially variant fixed charge
creates an electric field.
What do I mean by that?
I mean that if you have
a high concentration
of fixed charge over here and
a lower concentration of fixed
charge over here, an
electric field will develop.
And that's the
expression right there
that relates-- that describes
this in mathematical terms
where we're using psi here
as our electric field.
We're using psi instead of e.
You probably remember
your physics textbooks
using e as the electric
field because we're
going to reserve that variable
for the electron energy.
That will come in
several slides forward.
So the charge
density will be given
by that rho and the material
permittivity by our epsilon.
And an example is
a capacitor here.
All I've done is expanded
the dimensionality
of the derivative here.
I'm looking at the capacitor.
I have fixed charge
on either side.
And I have electric
field in between.
Now, this right here, obviously
in the case of a capacity,
you're under high vacuum.
Just as a very quick aside,
this is-- I can't resist.
This is really an
interesting historical note.
This space right here in
the diode as we recall,
where you have the thermionic
emission of the electrons going
off to the other plate, this
space right instead of here
is called the space
charge region.
Keep that name in mind.
We're going to come back
to it in several slides.
So a bit of history there.
So we have the capacitor
as our prime example.
We have fixed charge on
either side and electric field
in between.
And note that the charge
will move parallel
to the electric field.
If there's no electric
field-- in other words,
if we're just exciting
charge inside of a bare piece
of silicon with
no electric field
applied-- imagine
our batteries here
are taken out of the circuit.
We'll have simple
Brownian motion
of those photo-excited electrons
until they decay back down
into their ground state.
However, if we apply
an electric field,
now we have the Brownian motion.
But superimposed on top
of it, a certain drift
of the electrons in response
to that electric field.
And we can describe this
mathematically as well.
The drift currents for
holes and electrons being
described by the charge q.
Note that the charge
q is going to be
different for the electrons
and the holes-- the same value,
but negative or positive.
The mobility of holes and
mobility of electrons.
The density of
holes or electrons.
And then finally, the
electric field right here.
And the reason in this
equation you typically
see the q's being
the same value here,
although no minus
sign is put in front,
is because under the
same electric field,
you'll have electrons drifting
in this direction and holes
drifting in the
opposite direction.
So it's important to keep these
signs straight in your mind.
Yeah, question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Absolutely.
So p and n denote
the concentrations
of free electrons or
free hole-- actually,
free holes for free
electrons, respectively.
So you can almost think
of p as being synonymous
with the density of boron atoms.
If every hole is
ionized, meaning
dissociated from the dopant
atom and free to move around
the crystal, then
the density of holes
and the density
of boron atoms is
going to be almost identical.
Likewise, for
phosphorus atoms and/or
the donor atoms
and the electrons,
you'll have almost
an equal number.
So that's right here.
The n is related to
the number of electrons
that are free to move
around the crystal.
The p, the density of holes
that are free to move around
in the crystal.
And these are given in units
of number of particles charge
carriers per unit volume.
So per centimeter
cubed, let's say.
Question.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
you're creating more holes.
So is that not on the
same order of magnitude
as the number of holes
introduced by [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, absolutely.
So the density of holes and
electrons here in the dark
is dictated by the
dopant density.
Where are we?
Right here, for instance,
the dopant density.
If we add light, that's
a complicating factor.
The intrinsic population
of electrons and holes
and the dopant concentration
of electrons and holes,
we are adding a photo-generated
population as well.
Let's leave that
for next lecture
and try to simplify things.
So we just discussed
the diode in the dark.
Perhaps we turn the light
off here just for effect.
So we're trying to take this
piece by piece, so that we
can really construct
everything and not add too
much into the pot at one time.
I wanted to discuss the
notion of electron drift.
And I also wanted to
review the concept
of diffusion, which everyone
should be familiar with.
This is the reason why
we're breathing right now,
and why all the air
molecules aren't crowded
into that corner of the room.
It's because of Fick's law,
the process of diffusion.
If we have a concentration of
a particular species in one
spatial location, the natural
tendency through random motion
is for that concentration
to distribute
itself equally throughout.
And this is described
very nicely by Fick's law.
If we want to describe
a current to it,
we would then describe
the current of holes
and the current of electrons
by, again, the charge.
The diffusivity, this is
a quantity typically given
in units of centimeters
squared per second.
And the gradient.
In other words, the
concentration gradient.
In this case, in one dimension.
And that, again, should
be review for most folks
from physics.
And so we can see here
two different methods
of currents, two different
methods of current flow inside
of a semiconductor device.
We can have diffusion
or we can have drift.
Drift occurs when
there's an electric field
present and diffusion occurs
when-- well, in this case,
diffusion can occur in the
absence of an electric field
simply when there is a
concentration gradient present.
So we can envision,
just quickly,
that if we have an
electric field confined
to a certain region of
our solar cell device,
the electric field will be
dominant in one portion.
And if the rest of
our device we don't
have a strong electric field,
but the electrons nevertheless
can sense the electric
field far away
because of the
concentration gradient,
diffusion can drive
those electrons--
can drive those electron
toward the electric field.
So in our solar cell device,
the ratio of drift and diffusion
current will change as
a function of distance
from the pn-junction,
from the built-in field.
OK, so I want everybody
to upload into their RAM
the checkerboard example
that we went through.
Because this will be important
for understanding the next few
slides.
So let's imagine these
n-and p-type materials are
in contact, but there's
this imaginary barrier
right between them.
Here are p-type materials,
here are n-type materials.
And let's parse
through this figure.
Let's dwell, just a minute.
So we have this
imaginary boundary
between p-type material over
here and n-type material.
The boundary is right
here in the middle.
The blue dots here
are representing
mobile holes, holes that
are free to move around
the material.
And while there's this
imaginary barrier here,
these holes are just
moving in Brownian motion.
There's no net current.
There's no net charge flow.
These minus signs that are left
behind are the boron atoms.
The boron atoms have one
less proton in their nucleus
than the silicon atoms do.
And so the hole plus
the negative charge
that's within the boron
atom core if you will,
that combination is neutral.
So we haven't perturbed the net
charge of the entire system.
But locally, if we draw a
little circle around these two
for instance, the boron
atom that's fixed,
that's not moving.
The boron atom is bound to
the neighboring silicon atoms.
It's not moving around.
And the hole, which is free
to move around the material,
now we have net
charge neutrality.
But if that hole
moves too far away,
then you could have
a field building up.
On the other side, very similar.
Here we have phosphorus atoms
embedded within our silicon
lattice.
The phosphorus atoms have one
extra proton in their nucleus
than the silicon atoms do.
Hence, we denote that as a
positive charge right here.
And there's an extra electron
associated with the phosphorus
atoms.
Now as those electrons move
around, when it's in isolation,
again, there's no
net charge flow.
There's no current.
And we have a situation
of net charge neutrality.
Question is, what
happens if we remove
the barrier in between the two?
Let me ask you just
a basic question.
Would the phosphorus atoms
diffuse over to this side?
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: Probably not,
because the phosphorus atoms are
bound to 4 silicon neighbors.
Those bonds are really
tough and it's probably not
going to break.
Unless you heat it up to
a pretty high temperature.
But the electrons are
free to move around.
They're in the conduction band.
They're able to move.
And because the binding
energy to the phosphorus atoms
is on that order of
10 m EV on that order,
the thermal energy here
at room temperature
is enough to dissociate
them, and to allow
those electrons to move away
from the phosphorus atom thanks
to the screening potential
of the surrounding lattice
and thanks to the fact that the
electrons inside of a crystal
are more easily-- can more
easily move than in vacuum.
So when we remove that
boundary in between,
what begins to happen?
So we've removed the boundary.
We have these two materials
in direct contact.
The nuclei are not moving.
The fixed charge associated
with the boron atoms
in this side and the
phosphorus atoms on that side
are not moving.
However, the instant you remove
this boundary in between,
there is a high concentration
of electrons over here
and a very low concentration
of electrons over there, which
means that you will have
a diffusion process.
So the concentration gradient
drives the electrons over
to this side.
Likewise, holes are being
driven from here over to here.
Now, notice what happens.
Holes carry a positive charge.
The fixed charge from the
phosphorus is also positive.
So you have a buildup
of net positive charge
on this side of the junction.
Electrons are negative
charge carriers.
The boron atoms have a
net negative charge here.
And so you have a
net negative charge
building up on this side.
And now you have
a field beginning
to develop, an electric field.
And at some point, this
built-in electric field
will counteract the
diffusion process.
The diffusion current is driving
electrons in this direction,
but the field will be driving
them back the other way.
And it's that equilibrium that
establishes the pn-junction.
It's that equilibrium
that defines
the width of this region here,
this transition region, which
comes in a variety of names.
The transition region is also
called the depletion region.
And it's also called
the space charge region.
Interesting how these words
and terms come back into use.
So that's the essence of the
formation of this junction.
We have this
diffusion process that
drives the carriers from
this side into this side.
And then as we have the
electrons moving over
here, and summing to
the boron nuclei that
are left behind once
the holes, likewise,
have moved over
to the other side.
We have a buildup of net
negative charge on this side,
a buildup of net positive
charge on that side,
and the establishment of
a built-in electric field.
That's cool.
It takes a while
to really get it.
And so the chessboard
example was brilliant.
I thank Joe for that.
And hopefully, this
as well reinforces
several of those concepts.
And it might take some time
studying it on your own
or setting up special
office hours with Joe
or coming to my office
hours on Mondays.
But whatever it takes, make
sure that you understand
this concept well--
the fundamental--
gaining an intuition
about the concept.
We'll be getting
into the math soon.
And if you don't have a
good, solid understanding
of the intuition of where
charges are moving around,
it becomes less easy, let's
say, to really get the math.
So we have a buildup
of net charge
on either side of the junction.
We have a buildup of
net negative charge
on one side of the
junction and a buildup
of net positive charge on the
other side of the junction.
And this line
right here is meant
to represent that dividing
line where the two materials
initially came together.
So the dashed line is meant
to represent the real charge
distribution and the
boxed colored rectangles,
the rectilinear boxes, are meant
to represent an approximation
that we'll use for the
rest of today's class.
We're making successive
approximations
here because we want the
mathematics to be manageable.
You can, of course, discretize
this entire material
in one dimension, for instance,
and do a finite element
solution.
We'll show you the equations
that you can use to do that
later on in today's class.
So we have the net
charge distribution
on either side of the
junction shown here.
We also have, as a result
of that net charge,
an electric field.
And this goes back to Gauss'
law, or the derivative form
there of.
And so we have here a built-in
electric field as you can see.
And the field reaches a maximum
right here in the middle.
So that kind of makes sense.
If you're too far away
from that junction,
you're not going to-- if
you're a charge carrier,
you're not going
to see the field.
But if you're right there in
the middle of that junction,
that field is going
to be very strong.
You'll be swept out of
there pretty quickly.
That's why the field
reaches a maximum right here
in the middle.
So that intuitively
makes a lot of sense.
Now, if we take one further
integral of the electric field,
here the electric
field, arc psi.
If we integrate our arc psi,
we will get the potential.
And this potential right
here essentially follows
this wave-like
curve, where you have
a lower potential on
this side and a higher
potential on that side.
And if we take this potential
and translate it into something
that we can understand,
which is electron energy,
by multiplying the
potential by q.
And q in the case of an
electron is a negative number.
That's why we're flipping this.
So we're flipping
this upside down
because we're multiplying
this value here
by a negative number.
Now, what we can
see is that there's
an energy gain for the electron
by going from the p-side
to the n-side.
This is the electron energy.
Obviously, if you give
them an opportunity,
all the electrons would want
to come down to this side.
But why wouldn't all of
them come down over here?
AUDIENCE: Because of diffusion.
PROFESSOR: Because of diffusion.
So there's that balance
of the two effects.
So there is a net energy
gain for the electrons,
but diffusion is what's
driving some of the electrons
back across the other
side of the junction is
that equilibrium, which is
establishing the final energy
band diagram of the pn-junction,
which is really looking
something very much like that.
So this right here describes
for you how you go from atoms
and charge carriers
up at the top
to charge distribution, electric
field, potential, and finally
electron energy.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Are
these four diagrams
specifically for electrons?
Would the hole
ones be [INAUDIBLE]
the reverse of that?
PROFESSOR: So if you wanted to
look in terms of hole energy,
this equation here
would be equally valid,
but your charge would
be a positive value.
And so you'd have a curve that
looked very similar to this one
right here, where there'd be a
net energy gain for the holes
to go on to the other side.
And that's what establishes
the separation of charge.
AUDIENCE: So the bottom one is
the only one that would change
[INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: That's correct.
Yep.
Everything else identical.
So this is important,
this electron energy.
And this jump right here
confuses a lot of folks.
Because in books, they don't
often describe very clearly
what is potential
and what is energy,
almost using those two
terms interchangeably.
But it's that cue, the
fact that the electron has
a negative charge that
sets things right.
OK, this is pretty important.
This is the foundation,
the fundamental,
of how a pn-junction
comes into being.
And the summary of
our understanding
so far is that when
the light-- here we go.
When light creates an
electron-hole pair,
a pn-junction can separate the
positive and negative charges
because of the built-in
electric field.
Let me repeat that
one more time.
When light creates an
electron-hole pair,
a pn-junction
potentially can separate
the positive and
negative charges
because of that
built-in electric field.
For very small
light intensities,
very small light
intensities, such
that you can think of that
photo-generated carrier
as a perturbation to the
system, not fundamentally
altering the energy levels
yet-- it does eventually happen.
But if you have, say,
one photon coming
into your material
exciting electron
over here, that
electron can move down,
can be swept out of
the device, because
of that built-in electric field.
Again, assuming that we
have a very small impact
on the electrostatic
[INAUDIBLE] system
that it's just a
small perturbation,
maybe one single
electron in our system
is not going to affect you
much because we have 10
to the 23 or so atoms
per cubic centimeter.
We have a very small
perturbation to our system,
that charge carrier will
be swept out very quickly.
The built-in electric
field is established
at a pn-junction because of the
balance of electron and hole
drift and diffusion currents.
Let me be more precise about
this one point right here.
Because the built-in
electric field
is established at a
pn-junction because
of the balance of electron
drift and diffusion.
We talked about that.
But hole drift and
diffusion as well.
So if you go back over to here,
notice how the electron drift
and diffusion are opposed and
equal and opposite to the hole
diffusion and drift.
So let's think about it
from this perspective
right back here.
This is clear, our
electron diffusion
is going in that
direction because we
have a high concentration
of electrons
that tend to move toward the
low-concentration regime.
So our electron
diffusion current
is pointing toward the left.
Our hole diffusion current
is pointing to the right.
And the hole drift current,
because of this built-in field,
is pointing opposite
the hole diffusion.
So the hole drift current
will be pointing to the left.
Whereas, the electron
drift current
would be pointing to the right.
So we have, in total,
four currents here.
The way to think about it
would be, for example, let's
take the electrons first.
Electron drift or electron
diffusion and drift counteract.
And then you can take the holes.
Hole diffusion and
drift counteract.
They're all balanced.
And this is resulting in
zero net current flow when
you have no illumination and
no external field applied
to that device.
That's pretty nifty.
So the built-in electric
field is established
at the pn-junction because
of the balance of drift
and diffusion current for
both electrons and holes.
So we have a small
in-class exercise.
I'd like you to take out these.
And I'd like you
to work in pairs.
So that if anybody reaches
a small stumbling block,
you can help each other
work through the problems.
So first off, let's focus on
this upper left-hand portion
right here as shown right there.
This is a replica of
the sheet that you
should have in front of you.
So what we're doing is we're
dividing-- we're considering
the pn-junction under no bias.
That means that we're
not applying a battery
to our pn-junction.
So we have a pn-junction and
we don't attach a battery
in series.
We just have the pn-junction
under zero bias conditions.
So the way we'd represent that
in that equivalent or model
circuit diagram
right here is notice
how we have these
little lines extending
from the p- and the
n-regions and going above.
Those represent the
external circuit outside
of the actual device.
The device would be
this one right here
where we have p and our n.
We have our positive
and negative charges
here representing the
charges that have built up
in that space charge
region that are creating
the built-in electric field.
And under no bias conditions--
I'll give you the answer.
It's pretty straightforward.
We would just draw
a straight line
across right there bridging that
external circuit because there
is no external bias.
There is no battery applied.
And so from an energy band
diagram, e versus x, for e
being the electron
energy in this case.
And our p-type material
being on this side
and our n-type material
being on that side,
let's draw the energy band
diagram, just like we've done
or we've alluded to so far.
Sketch out the energy band
diagram for this pn-junction.
And I'll give you a hint.
It's going to look something
very similar to that right
there, except that you'll
have to take into account both
the conduction
and valence bands,
because they're both affected
in a similar manner to that.
So why don't you go ahead
and give it your best?
Draw the energy band diagram
in terms of the electron energy
and position.
Notice your p-type on one
side, n-type on the other.
You can assume that
the point of division
is like right here
in the middle.
And for those who
are a little quick,
you can go on and draw
the relative magnitudes
of electron drift and
diffusion currents.
So why don't we give that
a quick, little shot?
Maybe 30 seconds to think
about it and another 30 seconds
to draw and chat over
it with your colleagues.
So we want to draw
the band diagram,
just to make sure
everybody's in the same page.
So we're going to
be starting out
with our valence band and our
conduction band over here.
And as we move toward
our space charge region,
as we move toward our depletion
region, our transition region
here in the middle, we're
going to see some effect.
We're going to see some bending
of the bands, if you will.
So your question
is to figure out,
do the bands do
something like this?
Or do they do
something like that?
Do the bands go up
or do they bend down?
And that should be a
relatively easy copy
and paste from two slides prior.
The correct answer
is, indeed, we
have the band bending
down like this.
So we would have the bands
higher on one side, lower
on the other.
The electron energy is
higher on the p-type side
than the n-type side.
So if we add one
electron to our system,
for example a
photo-generated carrier
from one photon coming
into our device,
that electron will have
the natural tendency
to go onto this side.
It will be swept down.
Note that the net
current flow inside
of the device, in the absence
of an external excitation,
like light or a battery pack
over here, an external bias
voltage source, the net
current flow is zero.
Because electron
diffusion is pointed
in that direction
and electron drift
pointed in that direction.
All right, good.
So now that we've done one
example, I wanted to-- oh,
one last thing.
So hole diffusion.
So this is electron
diffusion pointing
to the left and electron
drift pointing to the right.
Hole diffusion is pointing
to the right and hole
drift pointing to the
left as one might expect.
Let's try these two right now,
forward bias and reverse bias.
And your trick is to
figure out, if you
have a battery for instance,
if the battery looks like this.
This would be positive
terminal and negative terminal.
If you have a battery,
which way would you
align the battery to induce a
forward bias or reverse bias?
It's perhaps a little
bit beyond my expectation
of what you would get.
Let me add that for you.
Let me just give that
to you right here.
The forward bias
would look like that.
The reverse bias
OK.
And now the big question is,
what do the band diagrams
look like?
How would these look?
If we forward bias, if we
forward bias our device
and we inject electrons
into this side right here,
what would happen to our bands?
What would you
expect would happen?
We'll prove this out
in the next few slides,
but I want to see how
people's intuition is
doing this morning.
So as you bias a device,
you're shifting one level
relative to the other.
And so the basic question
that you have to answer is,
should it shift up or
should it shift down under
Forward and reverse
bias conditions?
Spend a minute.
Talk to your neighbor.
Discuss it.
All right, folks.
Why don't we tie it in?
We should be able to
get band diagrams that
look something like that.
I saw several of you
have already begun
reaching this consensus here.
Rationale?
An easy way to
think about this is,
if our battery is aligned with
our pn-junction in that way,
and we're injecting
electrons into one side,
we then have a large
electron diffusion current.
We have the bands shifting
in this direction.
Now the barrier, the energy
barrier for the electrons
to overcome, to go from the
region of high concentration
to the region of low
concentration, is smaller.
And you'll get a larger
diffusion current as a result.
More electrons will be moving
over that n-type silicon
into the p-type silicon.
And the drift current
will be smaller.
Notice here, the balance of the
two, if you add them together,
you have a net electron flow
in that direction, which
means you have a
net current flow
as defined by the flow
of positive charges
in the other direction.
A lot of definitions
to keep straight.
Whereas, under reverse bias
here, you're shifting the bands
like so.
Because you have the
large electric field,
the drift current will be
increased, but only slightly.
Because there's a limited
number of carriers here
that you can pull from
the p-type material.
And the diffusion current is
going to be drastically reduced
because now the energy barrier
is so large that the electrons
have a very hard time getting
from the n-type material
into the p-type material.
And then that net current flow
is in the opposite direction.
Does this make intuitive
sense to folks?
Ashley.
AUDIENCE: So when you touch
the battery [INAUDIBLE],
is the minus side injecting
electrons [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: OK.
So in between these
two, the easiest way
to go from battery to
electron energy band diagram
is to follow the same sequence
that we did over here.
And if you're thinking
battery, and you're
thinking positive
and negative, you're
shifting the potential of one
side relative to the other.
Then, take that potential shift
and flip it for the electron.
AUDIENCE: I follow why the
diagrams are the way they are.
But is it conceptually accurate
to think of the negative side
as putting more electrons
into the n-side?
PROFESSOR: One could.
AUDIENCE: Like
injecting carriers?
PROFESSOR: The way
I prefer to think
about it is that you're
changing the energy
levels, the potential one
relative to the other.
And as a consequence, you
have more electrons flowing
from that n-side to the p-side.
And that's what's pulling the
current through the circuit.
It's almost a tail wagging
dog, dog wagging tail.
But I would take a
slight preference
toward understanding it from
the perspective of if you change
the potential one
relative to the other,
and allow for a
greater diffusion
current, that motion of
electrons, the electron moving
from here to here,
will pull current
through the entire circuit.
And that's what you'll be
measuring with your external--
essentially, all of the
electrons in the circuit
are moving through.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] so
we've opposed the field that
was set up [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
We are opposing the
field that was set up
by the balance of the drift and
diffusion currents initially.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Under
the first bias, how
come the many electrons
in the anti-material
aren't [INAUDIBLE]
through the entire circuit
and injected into
the [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Certainly.
So the reverse bias is
such that the battery
is aligned to prevent that.
perhaps one simple way
of thinking about it.
Yeah, I think that would be
the way I would describe it
most accurately.
You could-- and you are
dragging some of the electrons
out through the
external circuit.
But what is driving the current
is mostly the drift current.
It's pulling carriers
from-- essentially,
through your external circle.
Because carriers are moving
from the p-type to the n-type
and creating that
charge imbalance
resulting in the drift current.
Why don't we continue
moving on just a little bit
because we have some nice
demos we'd like to get to.
I do know this is
really, really important.
And I would welcome
you, actually urge you,
encourage you to come to
some of the office hours
and our recitation as well.
I'd like to continue
moving forward
for the benefit of several
of those who may have seen
similar material in the past.
But let me, before we
move too far ahead,
on our I-V
characteristics, we still
don't know how to map an I-V
characteristic of that device.
We don't know how the current
voltage, I current V voltage,
we don't know how
the current voltage
response is going to look like
for that particular device.
But we do know that
under no bias conditions
we're at bias voltage equals 0.
So V is at 0.
And we know that we have
no net current flow.
And so our current is
going to be at 0 as well.
And so we know that
we're going to have
one point on our
I-V curve that's
going to be situated at 0, 0.
Likewise, in this
case over here,
we have electron diffusion
driving the circuit.
And in the other, we have
electron drift, which
is in the opposite direction.
And so you'd expect
that the current flow
in I under forward bias
conditions-- forward bias is
positive-- would be
somewhere up here.
And likewise,
under reverse bias,
that our current would
be opposite the sign.
So whereas we had positive
current over here,
we would expect negative
current over there.
So our I-V
characteristic is going
to look something like a
combination of one point
right here and some
function up in this quadrant
and some function
down in this quadrant,
just by glancing at
the net current flows
and the type of bias that
we've applied to our diode.
We'll come back to this
at the end of class
and confirm it using those
small apparatus over there.
So current flow
in a pn-junction.
We're going to describe the
nature of the drift, diffusion,
and illumination
currents in a diode.
Show the direction and
magnitude in the dark.
Eventually, we'll do
this under illumination
as well, but let's
just focus in the dark.
In fact, we've
already done this.
I've already-- I've
already tricked you
into doing learning objective
number 3 on your own,
before even describing the math.
But I will show you the
mathematics as well so that you
have the complete picture.
We have the diffusion current.
This is the essence
of diffusion current.
We talked about Fick's
law as well for holes
and for electrons.
We have our drift current.
We spoke about the nature
of the drift current
as well for holes and electrons.
And we know that by
combining the two,
we can describe the net current
flow across a pn-junction.
So by combining the two, by
combining drift and diffusion--
drift and diffusion for
electrons and holes--
we can describe the current
flow across that pn-junction.
So when the electric
field is large,
the drift current term
is going to dominate.
If you have a
large field, that's
going to be the dominant
current source if you will.
And when the electric
field is small,
diffusion is going to dominate.
So if we have a device
like this right here.
And if I told you that the
built-in electric field was
located pushed up toward
the top 1/100 of the device.
So it was located very
close to the surface.
You might surmise that
the drift current is going
to be having a large influence.
If you're a single
electron, you'll
feel the influence
of the electric field
near the front
surface of the device.
And deep within the bulk,
the diffusion current
is going to be driving the
carriers toward that junction.
There's a relationship
between the mobility
and the diffusivity of carriers.
It's known as the
Einstein relation.
And that's given
to you over there
on the right-hand side
for a band conductor.
Note that if you have--
this is an advanced concept.
But if you have a dispersive
hopping mechanism,
for instance, you may need
to become a little bit more
sophisticated in how you relate
the diffusivity of a carrier
to your mobility.
But let's assume that is
valid for nice, well-behaved
semiconductors.
It's just a warning for those
who work on organic materials.
I'd be happy to talk to you
more about that in a bit.
So again, we have Gauss' law.
The question is, what
is that electric field?
What is arc psi?
What is our built-in
electric field?
Well, we know that
the charge density
is going to be comprised
of the free hole
density, the free electron
density, the fixed
density of our donor atoms.
You could think of
these as the phosphorus,
the ionized phosphorus
atoms, and our fixed density
of ionized acceptor atoms.
We can also think of this as
our boron atoms and silicon.
And so that is our fixed--
actually, not our fixed.
These are fixed charges.
These are mobile charges.
But under equilibrium,
they've distributed themselves
in a certain way.
That is our charge
density, our rho.
And that will figure
into Gauss' law
and allow us to
calculate arc psi.
And so in summa, we have here
arc psi as a function of dx.
We have an expression that
relates the electric field
to the density of dopant
atoms inside of our material.
Note that we made one critical
assumption going from here
to here, where we went from
the ionized donor and acceptor
concentration to the total
dopant concentration.
We're assuming that
everything is ionized.
Again, because the
ionization energy,
because the binding energy
of those free carriers
to their dopant
atoms is so small
that under kt, under thermal
energy at room temperature
it's enough to
dissociate the charge.
OK, so we've gotten to here.
We can describe quantitatively
using this approximation,
using the box function
approximation.
We can describe the electric
field quantitatively.
And now we have to
get to the potential
and find the electron
energy as well.
So we do a little
bit of accounting.
If we want to account for
all of the electrons flowing
through our system,
we would have
to consider as well, in
any voxel of our material,
in any unit volume
of our material,
we have electrons going
in, electrons coming out.
And within it, we could have
electrons being generated,
say by light, or
electrons recombining.
Meaning they're
losing their energy
and falling back into a ground
state where they're bound.
And that's this
U-term right here.
And so the continuity
equations are essentially
a set of accounting
equations that
just describe the
difference, the net change,
going in and out.
If something changes
on either surface,
it's because your either added
carriers or took them away.
And the way you add is by
shining light on your sample
and generating more carriers.
G, for instance.
That's one way of generating
carriers by adding light.
Or recombination.
And one way of recombining
is, for example,
through a defect
in our material,
where the electron
is moving along.
It finds a defect and it falls
back into a ground state.
So the continuity equations
are nothing more, nothing less
than housekeeping, bookkeeping.
But it's very important as
you'll see in the next slide
right here where we
combine five equations that
describe current transport
in a pn-junction.
We have drift and
diffusion up here.
Those are the
equations we just saw.
We have the equation
describing the electric field.
And we have our accounting
equations down here.
And if we look at these
equations in unison,
we'll notice that, oh, well, we
have our hole current appearing
twice here.
We have our electric field
appearing in two cases.
Sorry.
Back.
There.
We have our electric field
appearing in those three
equations right here.
And we have a system
of non-linear equations
as a result. It is not possible
to solve these analytically
in their entirety.
We'll have to make a
series of assumptions
to really get to
the full solution.
But it's possible to
solve them numerically
using computer simulations.
This is important
because we want
to be able to define the current
coming out of our solar cell
device.
Without solving these
equations, we really
don't understand what
the current is out
of a pn-junction, out of a
solar cell under different bias
conditions.
That's why these equations
right here are important.
What I want to do is not to
just dwell on the current.
I want to emphasize
that to calculate
the voltage across the
semiconductor-- sorry,
a semiconductor device, a
pn-junction-based solar cell.
To calculate the voltage
across a solar cell,
we have to understand
a little bit more.
So far, we've been assuming
that each electron is
a unique individual.
That an electron over here
is a small perturbation
to a larger system in
that it will flow down
based on that electric field.
For a voltage,
we're really talking
about an ensemble of electrons.
All of the electrons
in the system.
And so we have to define
some chemical potential
for our system.
We have to define
some-- one could
think of it as an average
energy for our system.
So let me define chemical
potential for you
in a semiconductor.
If we describe the
semiconductor-- here's
our valence band and
our conduction band.
This is our band gap right
here in between the two bands
as described by e sub g, our
conduction band, valence band.
And these little red dots
here are representing
our covalently bonded
electrons in the ground
state at 0 Kelvin.
If we heat this material
up just a little bit,
there will be some
fraction of carriers
moving across into the
conduction band just
through simple probability.
And we'll get to the
precise equation that
describes the
probability distribution
function in a few lectures.
But for now, let's just
assume that a certain number
through thermal
processes are able to be
excited across the band gap.
So these are
thermally-excited electrons.
And we call these-- this
is the intrinsic carrier
concentration.
So these carriers up here
are free to move around
the crystal.
They can conduct electricity.
They can conduct charge.
We could measure
a current flowing
through if we applied a
bias voltage across material
like this.
Those are our charge carriers.
These holes as well.
And so this is the intrinsic
carrier concentration.
To give you an
order of magnitude
of the intrinsic carrier
concentration in silicon,
it's around 10 to the 10
carriers per cubic centimeter.
That's 1 over 10
to the 12 per atom.
So each atom of silicon is
generating roughly 1 over 10
to the 12 free carriers
due to this process.
Very small concentration of
free carriers in the material.
Around 5/10 into the 22
atoms per cubic centimeter
and only 10 to the 10 free
carriers per cubic centimeter
due to this thermal process
at room temperature.
So it's a very small
effect in silicon.
As you shrink your
band gap, the energy
necessary to excite
across a band gap
becomes less since you
have more thermal carriers.
So the chemical potential is
describing the average energy
necessary to remove an
infinitesimally small quantity
of electrons to the system.
And again, infinitesimally
small quantity meaning it's
a mere perturbation.
You're not changing the volume.
You're not changing the
electrostatics of the system.
You're just adding one
electron to the system,
or taking it away,
and determining
how much energy was required.
And so we describe that
chemical potential,
we call it by a different name.
We call it Fermi level, but
it is the exact same thing.
It's the energy necessary
to remove that electron
from the material.
So you can envision
that it's going
to be the Fermi level on either
side of the pn-junction that
will determine the voltage
output of our solar cell
device.
And that's why we want to
be able to calculate this.
So let's look, first off what
happens to our Fermi level
when we dope our material,
when we intentionally
add, in this case, boron
atoms to make it p-type
or phosphorus atoms to
make the material n-type.
What happens?
Well, we end up
shifting our Fermi level
toward the valence band
or shifting the Fermi
level toward the conduction
band by the addition of holes
or electrons.
An easy way to think
about it without getting
into complicated semiconductor
math is the following.
If I'm adding more electrons to
my system, by doping at n-type,
essentially I'm shifting
the energy level up.
It's an easy way
to think about it.
If I'm removing the
electrons from the system
by adding holes
down here, then I'm
shifting the Fermi level down.
Easy way to think about it.
We'll get to the math.
Actually, if you're
really curious,
I think I included one
slide of the derivation
of the precise
chemical potential
so you can walk
through that as well.
So voltage across a pn-junction.
Under zero bias conditions,
this is in the dark
and without a battery
pack attached to it.
So this is an
unperturbed pn-junction
just in the dark without
any external bias.
We have the Fermi level
constant throughout.
Both the p-type and
the n-type flat.
Notice the bands are
bending, so the distance
of the Fermi level
from the valence band
here is smaller than the
distance from the Fermi level
to the valence band in
the n-type material.
That's because in
the n-type material
we have more
electrons, and we're
pushing the Fermi level higher.
The vacuum level
follows these bands.
It just happens to
be way up there.
And so the amount of
energy necessary to remove
the electron from the system,
to move it to the vacuum level,
changes from the
p-type to the n-type.
But for the purposes
of our diagram right
here, we're drawing the Fermi
level constant throughout.
Now, we have that transition
region, the depletion region,
the space charge region--
all anonymous, same thing.
We have that transition
region here in the middle.
So if we begin quantifying
the different parameters here,
we have a Fermi level distance
from the valence band.
So that's this
distance right here.
We have the distance
between the Fermi level
and the conduction band
in the n-type material.
And then we have our
built-in potential.
And when we multiply our
built-in potential by q,
we get an energy.
Essentially, an energy gain
across that pn-junction.
So that quantity here is equal
to the band gap minus these two
parameters.
Minus this, minus that.
And so you can see that
the built-in potential
across the junction is
benefited by higher doping.
The higher we dope
our material, the more
we shift our Fermi level
toward either band.
And the greater the
separation we get,
the smaller this quantity is,
the smaller that quantity is,
and the more our built-in
potential approximates
the actual band gap
of the material.
This built-in potential
will relate to-- it
wont' be identical
to, but it will
be associated with
our maximum voltage
that we can get
out of the device.
And so we'll want to engineer
our material in such a way
so as to maximize that quantity.
That's important.
The relation between our
built-in potential and the dope
intensity is shown here.
For now, you'll have
to take my word for it.
I'm sparing you a lot of
semiconductor physics.
It's written on the next
slide right here if you
care to look in some detail.
It's also described in,
I believe, Chapter 2
in Martin Green's textbook.
But for now, let's assume that
the built-in junction potential
is a function of the
dopant concentrations
just by our intuition.
If we're adding more
electrons to one side,
we're going to be shifting
the Fermi energy up.
OK, so the voltage
across a pn-junction.
Now, let's bias our device.
We have under zero bias
conditions this expression.
Sorry, there we go.
Under zero bias conditions,
we have that expression there.
And under biased
conditions, now we
have an applied biased
voltage, our V sub a.
We're applying a bias voltage.
We've effectively
shifted-- notice here,
we've shifted our bands
when relative to the other.
So we've shifted this side
up by a certain V sub a.
And now if you'll notice
the quantities here,
we have a separation
of the Fermi energy
on one side to the other.
There is a bias now
across this device.
There is a driving
force for electrons
to go and complete an
external circuit, to travel
through the external circuit.
Because the electrons
that are over
here have a higher energy net
than the electrons over there--
the ensemble, on average.
The transition region,
likewise, will get smaller.
Sorry for that animation.
But if we keep track here,
the transition region
becomes smaller
under forward bias.
Because we're depleting-- we're
removing the amount of charge
that was over here.
We're squeezing it back.
We're reducing that
barrier height.
And so over here, if we
go back to this diagram,
you can now draw in what's
written in these red circles.
You can draw in the
actual depletion
width, the width of the space
charge region on your diagrams,
just like that.
I'll give you just a second to
complete that diagram there.
Under reverse bias, likewise,
the width of the depletion
region will increase.
And the depletion
region is increasing,
the built-in charge
is increasing,
the amount of band
bending is increasing,
and the amount of drift
current also increasing.
So it all fits together.
It's beginning to really
come together nicely in one
nice picture in our minds.
So yes, one question.
AUDIENCE: So I understand
that for our solar cell,
we wouldn't want to actually
use a battery to drive current.
PROFESSOR: Let's get to
illuminated current next class.
For now, we'll just
focus on the battery.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So should we
not quite yet understand
why forward bias and reverse
bias applies to [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Let's leave
that for next class.
For now, let's assume that the
illumination current-- if you
really want to satisfy
your curiosity,
your illumination
current is going to be
one additional arrow to this.
It's going to be in addition
to everything else that's
going on.
But the majority of
the field is going
to be created by what is
doped into the material.
So think of the
illumination for now
as a small perturbation
to the system.
That's the easiest
way to think about it.
To justify to
yourself why we need
to understand first the
solar cell in the dark,
and then because of
that small perturbation,
we can treat it as a linear
superposition of effects.
And we'll add the
illumination next class.
But bear with me
in the dark first.
Because if we really
don't understand this,
we're not going to
understand fully
how the solar cell operates
in the light either.
So next, we'll draw
the I-V response.
We'll want to really
get to this last point
right here where we can draw
the current voltage response.
And we want to recognize
that minority carrier flux is
what's regulating the current.
So to do this well,
to do this properly,
we have to shift
our focus from here
where we were talking
about ensembles
and individual particles.
Here we're going
to be discussing
in terms of carrier densities
on either side of the junction.
Densities of
electrons and holes.
And unfortunately,
I'm going to have
to move rather quickly
through these slides.
This is the essence of
why a solar cell behaves
like a diode.
And it's really
something that is best
done by studying on your own.
I'm happy to walk you through
the most salient points,
the most important
approximations
that we have along the
way, but this is best
understood by going
home, looking up
the readings on stellar, and
walking through the derivation
yourself.
It's not something
that very easily I
can convey a series of
equations in the class.
So before we go into
detail into current flows,
I wanted to touch on this
with the space charge region.
We can describe the width
of the space charge region
now by the built-in bias
across the junction.
The applied bias right here
and some fundamental material
properties as well.
And this little
epsilon right here
is essentially the dielectric
constant and the vacuum
permittivity, a constant.
And so you want to
take that into account
when you're running your
actual calculations.
It's very easy to be off on
the width of the space charge
region by several
orders of magnitude
if you don't do the proper
accounting for those fixed
variables.
And so if you walk
through the equations
to describe the width of
the space charge region,
you'll find that in a
typical solar cell device,
it's on the order of a micron.
And this is related to one
of your homework problems,
so stash that away
somewhere in your brain.
It's on the order of a micron.
The width of that
space charge region
typically could
be on that order.
So it's going to
be some multiple.
And the reason
that's interesting
is because the entire
solar cell device
is about 100 to 200 microns.
That's for a crystalline
silicon device.
That means that in a
crystalline silicon device,
the diffusion current
is what's driving
most of the current flow
inside of the solar cell.
If our solar cell is
much, much, much thinner,
say in the order of a micron,
then our drift current
would be dominating.
This is a more advanced
topic and we'll
return to that when we
describe the differences
between thin film operation and
crystalline silicon solar cell
operation.
Device capacitance.
For those who are running
experimental measurements
and want to determine
the RC time constant
necessary to have the device
settle into a measurable state,
that's there.
And the capacitance
is described, again,
by the various
properties as well as
the built-in potential which is
related to the dopant density.
OK, so under zero bias,
we have a concentration
of holes on one side of
our junction that's high.
In the p-type material, the
concentration of holes is high.
And it's approximately equal
to the acceptor concentration.
On the n-type side
of our junction,
the whole population
is drastically reduced.
And the flip side, our electron
concentration is very high
and it drops into
the p-type side.
So we have predominately
holes on this side.
Predominately
electrons in that side.
But a small concentration
of holes on the n-type side
and a small concentration of
electrons in the p-type side.
And we call this the
minority carrier.
And we call that the
majority carrier.
The majority carrier
is in the majority.
The minority carrier
in the minority.
And an interesting thing
happens when we bias our device.
When we bias our
solar cell device,
populations of both
carriers increase.
But because this
is on a log scale,
we're increasing this-- shall
we say the minority carrier
concentration in an
absolute sense by a lot.
And it's because of this drastic
uptick in the minority carrier
concentration right at the
edge of the space charge region
that we have current flow
across that junction.
And that's described by a
series of equations here.
Let's see, the way to walk
through the derivation,
there's a series of
approximations to make.
Think of it in terms of
electron and hole fluxes
on either side of the junction.
You can make a series of
assumptions as to what currents
matter and which don't.
You can, of course,
make the assumptions
as to the charge
distribution as well,
fixed using that box potential.
And you can consider the cases
in which the minority carrier
concentration here is dominating
to be the regions of interest
for a current generation
inside of our device.
And so if we walk through,
again the diffusion equation,
the diffusion of carriers
at the edge of the space
charge region.
And from the
previous slides here,
add our approximations
in, we will ultimately
derive an expression that
has an exponential relation
between current and our voltage.
And if we continue through
the series of calculations,
including the continuity
equation for accountability,
we wind up with
an expression that
looks like this right here,
where the total current flowing
through the device will be
equal to the electron current
at the edge of our space
charge region coming
from the p-type side.
The hole concentration
coming from the n-type side.
The addition of
the two together.
And that's effectively,
this equation right here,
where we have an exponential
relation between current
and voltage.
So again, this we really
need to go home and study.
And if you'd like to
do this pictorially,
I provide you with
that link right there
so you can see it visually.
If you're more of a math type,
Chapters 3 and 4-- actually,
Chapter 4 in Martin Green is
probably the best place to go.
And the important
thing to keep in mind
is that in the pn-junction,
the current flow
across that junction
is determined
by the minority carrier current
flow at the edge of the space
charge region.
And that's why we wind up
with the exponential relation
between voltage and current.
I decided the best
way to emphasize
this voltage-current relation
is actually to measure it,
to run it.
To do it.
And we have around 10 minutes
left before the end of class.
Do you think that is
time for our demo?
Cutting it kind of short.
AUDIENCE: Probably
wait for Tuesday.
PROFESSOR: Probably wait
for Tuesday on the demo.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So we're going
to run the demos on Tuesday,
I suppose.
Because we're running a
little bit short on time.
I know David is
really disappointed
because he's been
working hard to get
these in perfect
ship-shape condition.
But we'll have
another couple of days
to work out some of the
bugs in the software,
so we don't need to
restart it every time we
take a new I-V measurement.
But by and large,
what we'll do is
we'll measure the
current voltage relation
for a real solar cell device.
And we'll see that it
definitely does follow,
at least under forward
bias conditions,
this exponential relation.
So as v goes forward,
as v-- this v over here
is our applied bias condition.
As our v increases, we have
that exponential current output
from our device.
As v goes towards
a negative number,
we have pretty much a flat
lining of our current.
It goes into a slightly negative
condition and a flat lining
of the current.
So if we look at this again
right here, our I versus V,
now we can plot
the same equation.
Or essentially, the same
curve on all three of these.
We'll want to plot the same
curve-- this one over here.
And for now, let's assume
that this big lump over here
is a constant.
And so we just need to plot an
exponential function, something
similar to this right here.
And under zero bias conditions,
we'll be right there at 0, 0.
Under forward bias conditions
will be further up.
And the reverse bias
conditions will be down there.
And let me give you a second
just to draw this down.
And please do.
We'll be validating it
to ourselves on Tuesday.
My sincere apologies for not
having enough time to really
go into the demos as well.
But suffice to
say the following.
Under forward bias
conditions, when
we reduce the barrier
height between the n-
and the p-type side, we're now
allowing that diffusion current
from the n to the
p to take over.
And as we reduce the barrier
more and more and more,
we have this exponentially
increasing density of electrons
flowing through our system.
And that's why we have this
exponentially increasing
curve here.
As we reverse bias--
our device, we're
increasing the barrier height
for the electrons to pass over.
So our diffusion current
practically vanishes.
And our drift current
stays, more or less,
constant all the way
throughout because there's only
a finite carrier density,
a finite minority carrier
concentration inside
of the p-type silicon.
The thermally excited
carriers for instance,
that are finding their way
to the junction and being
drifted across.
And that concentration
is virtually finite.
At some point, you'll
reverse bias this so much
that the carriers will
begin tunneling across
from the valence band into
the conduction band over here
and you'll have a catastrophic
failure of your device,
but that's more of
an advanced point.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So does the x indicate
the coordinate of I and V
at steady state?
PROFESSOR: So the
entire line represents
the I-V characteristic
under all biased conditions.
The x represents the
current and voltage
for this particular operating
point on the solar cell.
On the I-V characteristic.
So if you're under
forward bias condition.
In other words,
your v is positive,
you will have a positive current
flow through your device.
Positive current flow,
electrons flowing that way.
And under reverse bias,
notice the sign of the current
is flipped because
now the electrons used
to be going that way.
The electrons are predominately
moving the other direction.
The net current flow is
in the opposite direction.
And the voltage is
also changing sign.
AUDIENCE: You can
say, OK, I'm going
to put myself in this voltage?
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
And that's important
because we want
to be able to describe
what our current voltage
characteristic is
of a solar cell
because the product of
the two is the power.
For efficiency, we want
to know what the power out
of our solar cell is.
And it's the product
of current and voltage
that will give us the power
of our solar cell device.
Time for a few
questions, actually.
About five minutes of Q&A
since we had to forgo the demo.
Promise me you'll do one thing.
Promise me you'll go home.
And sometime between
now and Tuesday, you're
going to read through
these chapters
and do the derivations
that will work
through to this ideal
diode equation right here.
Because this is
pretty important.
And you have to
convince yourself
that that's indeed the case.
I can wave my hands
and phenomenologically
describe, OK, we have
an energy barrier.
I kind of get it.
I should have an
exponential probability
of passing over
an energy barrier.
At least from quantum mechanics
that kind of makes sense.
So I kind of get how if
I forward bias my device,
I'll have an exponentially
increasing diffusion current.
I get that if I go into
reverse bias conditions,
there's just a finite density
of carriers, minority carriers,
in my p-type material.
If I'm not, say, shining
a light on the material,
I'm not changing that
concentration by much.
And I'm going to flat line.
Yes, they'll be drifting
across, but they'll
be limited more by their
ability to reach the junction.
You can hand wave all you want,
but this is really-- whoopsie--
the equations that describe
the ideal diode equation.
Those are really where it's at.
With that equation,
you can really
understand how material
properties will
impact solar cell
performance, let's say.
Yes, question?
AUDIENCE: I have a question
about the band diagrams.
For all three diagrams, the
energy levels [INAUDIBLE]
the same.
We're just changing
where the n-type side is.
Both of them [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
Yep, absolutely.
The point was here, what we've
done for simplicity is shifting
one side relative to the other.
Yeah.
In energy-- see,
energy is a funny thing
because you can
redefine your zero.
Yeah.
So depending on where you're
defining your zero point at,
you can move things
relative to each other.
But let's assume
that you're changing
both sides relative to
some universal ground
potential that's off on
an external component
of your circuit.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: That's
a great question.
So the question was, when
you dope your material, what
are the experimental
methods that you
can use to really
determine whether or not
the atoms have occupied a
substitutional position?
One of the methods is called
Rutherford backscattering
or channeling, IN channeling,
where you introduce ions
down your lattice.
And if there is an
atom here, for example,
an interstitial
site, it will scatter
some fraction of those
introduced ions back
at the detector.
And so channeling is one
characterization method
for determining the interstitial
to substitutional ratio inside
of a semiconducting material.
Another way that we have
very strong evidence
that boron is occupying a
substitutional site and not
an interstitial site is we can
calculate the binding energy
of this hole to
the boron atom here
on the substitutional site.
In principle, if the
interstitial was also--
if it was a charge
to defect, we could
calculate the binding energy
of the charge to that defect.
And the density
functional theory
could tell you which
is the more likely
given your experimental
observation that you
get about one hole for every
one boron anatomy inside
of your sample.
Boron has been studied
to death in silicon.
It's pretty well-known
that it's substitutional.
But if you're working with a
new semiconducting material,
you never know.
You have to run the experiments.
Yeah, question.
AUDIENCE: Under bias
[INAUDIBLE] diagrams, are the p-
and n-sides far away
from the [INAUDIBLE].
Are those bands actually--
do they actually
have a slope to them because
of the applied field?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So the question was far away
from the space charge region
here, do these
bands have a slope?
My argument would be that
if we go back to the way
we derive-- there we go.
The way we derive this
band to begin with,
it's predicated upon an electric
field, which is predicated
upon a charge distribution.
So the biggest question is,
what does this real charge
distribution look like?
Most of the time,
it's relatively
concentrated to the near
space charge region.
If you get too far away, OK,
yes, it decays exponentially.
But it falls below the
background intrinsic carrier
concentration and
effectively doesn't matter.
AUDIENCE: Under applied
bias, [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Usually they're
just drawing it flat,
but is it such a small
effect they're just
drawing it flat [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So under applied
bias, what happens
to these charge distributions?
Well, if you reverse
bias it, you're
essentially increasing
the amount of charge
on either side of the junction.
If you forward bias,
you're reducing it.
So under forward
bias, probably you
wouldn't see the effect
you're describing.
Under reverse bias, the width
of the space charge region,
let's say, increases from, let's
call it 1 micron to 3 microns.
And the thickness of the
entire device is 200 microns.
So still, I think it would
be a relatively small effect
several 10's of microns
away from the junction.
It really depends
on the length scale,
the geometry of your device
relative to the length scale
of your space charge region.
Good?
Well, to give you time to reach
your next class, thank you.
We'll come back on Tuesday, and
we'll have a great demo set up
for you.